we make once again clear that the
international community will never
accept russia's illegal imperialist
annexation of ukraine territory
russian
unprovoked and unjustified war of
aggression against ukraine has been met
with a courageous defense by the
ukrainian people to them i pay my utmost
respect
their resolve and bravery are admired at
all over the world
they reject a world
where might makes right where great
powers can just swallow up smaller
states if they like
this summon demonstrates that today
ukraine's partners are more united than
ever
i want to repeat yet again that there
are no sanctions on food when the
russian regime blames sanctions for the
food crisis around the world they're
engaging in disinformation
we need to continue fighting russian
disinformation that's why canada will
create a dedicated team to help increase
our capacity to monitor and detect
russian and other state-sponsored
disinformation i want to congratulate uh
president vladimir zolensky particularly
uh for bringing us together and for
focusing our attention on russia's
illegal annexation of crimea
because that land grab in 2014 was the
direct precursor of today's war
and we should have the humility to
acknowledge that not everybody realized
the sheer enormity of what was happening
at the time putin
forcibly annexed the territory of a
european country
and forcibly
redrew
a european frontier
for the first time
since 1945.
he ignored the fact that russia itself
would repeatedly recognized crimea as
being part of ukraine
and he broke so many international
agreements that i can't list them all
and so it follows that we will never
recognize russia's annexation of crimea
or any other ukrainian territory
in the face of putin's assault
we must continue to give our ukrainian
friends
all the military humanitarian
economic
and diplomatic support
that they need
until russia
ends
this hideous war
and withdraws its forces
from the entirety of ukraine
this is
[Music]
[Music]
principles